When raw,
they rose to fight aids.
The foes we sprang to work and will,
when Laurie gave to drake the wave she
gave to us the hill,
this is the hill on which Harris
standards so they could look down on the
people below.
In every sense.
Looking back on it,
I sometimes feel that the only one of my
contemporaries at school who hasn't yet
been to jail is mark Faccia and it's not
for want of trying the Stanford
Education.
So many of our schools is so poor that
if you happen to go to a good one,
your privileged and at the heart of this
debate is the question,
is privilege a bad thing?
Is it a bad thing?
What about if that privilege has been
ernt?
What about if that privilege meet simply
means going to a better school than
average?
And what about if the word that is being
used as privileged,
when what we really mean is successful?
Of all those brilliant,
brilliantly educated young people honed
to perfection in the white heat of this
crucible of excellence,
who's bought education buys them the
best jobs in those monuments to selfless
wisdom.
The media,
law and banking.
I happen to think that a society in
which nobody has access in the original
language to homer,
Virgil,
you repertories or Ovid is a grossly
impoverished society.
I can't help thinking that if lady died,
been encouraged to get a few more gcse,
yes,
she would have done better in life.
Between the years 2003 and 2008 private
school fees went up by 43%.
The Independent Schools Council when
asked about their said,
ah,
well,
you see it's education,
inflation,
education,
what's there?
Was it the price of shore could suddenly
gone hugely are uh,
whatever it is they make.
Board dusters was running out in the
world and could only be kind of
purchased with gold.
All I do
is the Oracle gentleman on that side of
the house,
Uzi to such media chat shows and the
columns of the establishment organs,
which they write and draw and I
relapsed.
I accused them of being on chair.
Revolutionary is and Nuke Sop Marxists.